miles de niños han sido víctimas de la
guerra más de 310 han fallecido y
cientos más han quedado heridos como
consecuencia a los ataques
indiscriminados de las fuerzas rusas los
casos más críticos son traídos hasta
hospitales en la ciudad de leh vivo aquí
en la unidad de reanimación del hospital
san nicolás el doctor diadema benz nica
tiene a su cargo un equipo de
especialistas que por eso empeño en
salvarlos como es el caso de este
pequeño que se debate entre la vida y la
muerte la mayoría llegan en condiciones
médicas muy difíciles vienen con
infecciones graves como consecuencia de
las heridas tienen que recorrer un gran
trayecto para llegar aquí
la mayoría de los pacientes llegan desde
el este del país a cientos de kilómetros
de distancia
este pequeño de siete años fue traído
desde jarc y donde sufrió un ataque
cuando jugaba en un parque hoy está
fuera de peligro
mi hijo estaba en el epicentro del
ataque tuvo heridas muy graves el
diafragma el hígado una costilla partida
piezas de metralla entraron a sus
piernas es un milagro que esté vivo
decenas y decenas de niños que ya tenían
problemas antes de la guerra como
epilepsia o problemas en su crecimiento
han visto como su situación se empeora
con la llegada de la guerra
especialmente aquellos que viven en
poblaciones que son atacadas
constantemente por las fuerzas rusas
muchos de ellos han llegado al oeste del
país donde han encontrado apoyo
la ong que lo atiende a una treintena de
niños que vienen de poblaciones
alcanzadas por la guerra la mayoría han
sido testigos de bombardeos y vivieron
largos períodos en refugios subterráneos
como merche -que de 3 años que tenía
demoras en su desarrollo y estaba
evolucionando muy bien hasta que llegó
la guerra y todo se detuvo
en nuestra ciudad todo estaba cerrado
está está miedoso contarle que comíamos
esos días pero así fue cómo sobrevivimos
o no sé si se le puede llamar sobrevivir
porque no sabemos qué pasará después
el niño empezó a necesitar pañales y el
miedo se apoderó de él se encerró en sí
mismos desde hace menos de un mes asiste
varias veces por semana la terapia poco
a poco se recupera esto es un alivio
para la madre pero acaban sus problemas
la mayoría de familias han perdido sus
casas y muchas de ellas saben que no
podrán regresar a sus poblaciones un
gran número de ellas en poder de las
fuerzas rusas